مرحله جديده اخيرا وعد البلد المبتلى
بالحرب بمركبات القتاليه المدرعه ودبابات
حديثه لا خلاف على حاجه اوكرانيا اليها مع
تكليف الروس ضغطهم على جبهتكال
بوصول الدفعه الاولى من ذاك العتاد الهجوم
الثقيل على الارجح خلال شهرين او ثلاثه
سيرتفع الدعم الغربي
120 مليمتر
قد تزود الولايات المتحده اوكرانيا بعربات
القتاليه من طراز برادليه التي تزن 27
ومزوده بمدفعها هيار 25 ملمترا وسوارخ
خارقه للدروع فرنسا سترسل مركبات قتاليه
مدرعه خفيفه من طراز اي ام اكس 10 ار سي
المزوده بمدفع من عيار 205 ملمرات
ويناقش المسؤولون في المانيا امداد كيف
بدبابات قتاليه ومدرعات من طراز مارداف
التي يبلغ عيار يدفعها الاوتوماتيكي 25
ملم
لا شيء محسوما بعد في عواصم غربيه علقت
بين الحماسه والحذر فباريس ووارسو مثلا
تضغطاني على برلين بحسب تقارير غربيه
لاقناعها لارسال الدبابات حديثه ثقيله من
طراز لا يطارد اثنان الى اوكرانيا
ما نجيء نفاسم
داخلي ايضا في الدول الداعمه لاوكرانيا
حول جدوى ومحاذير نقل التسليح الى مربع
جديد من ذلك المناقشات جاريه في بريطانيا
منذ اسابيع بشان تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات
من طراز تشالنجر اثنان
ضلت الدول الغربيه لشهور تمتنع عن ارسال
الدبابات وعربات القتاليه المتطوره الى
الاوكرانيين خشيه اثاره غضب روسيا فماذا
تغير الان ربما تشيل خطوه بالرغبه في
تسريع استعاده اوكرانيا لاراضيها التي
باتت تحت سيطره الروس يرى خبراء ان
المركبات القتاليه ستساعد اوكرانيا في
استكشاف مواقع القوات الروسيه وكذا نقل
الجنود وضرب المركبات المدرعه الروسيه كما
انها توفر ميزه تكتيكيه كبيره لا سيما ان
كان الاوكرانيون يتطلعون الى اطلاقه هجوم
لاستعاده الاراضي هذا العام
لكن احدا لا يعتقد كما يبدو بان الاسلحه
الثقيله الجديده ستحقق التفوق او تحدد
بمفردها مسار الحرب والحرب يحذر الكرملين
من ان الخطط الغربيه لتزويد كيف باسلحه
اثقل هو ما سيطيل امدها بالنسبه
الاقدام على ذلك لا يحدث تغييرا ميدانيا
جذريا لمصلحه الاوكرانيين